(beeps)
(audience laughing and cheering)
[Casting Director] Name?
Nick Offerman.
This is Teen Dumbledore?
[Casting Director] That's right, how old are you?
28.
(audience laughing)
[Casting Director] Sorry, OK.
It does not do to dwell on dreams and forget to live.
(whips wand)
(audience laughing)
[Casting Director] Wow, yeah, that was great.
Do you want to try one while wearing the hat?
No.
(beeps)
(audience laughing)
[Casting Director] Name please.
(audience cheering)
Aubrey Plaza.
Harry Potter.
(audience laughing)
Harry?
Is it OK if I just do, um,
Marcia Gay Harden's monologue from Pollock instead?
(audience laughing)
[Casting Director] Sure, whatever works for you.
OK, what did you just say to me Pollock?
You want a baby?
Look at you with your drinking.
You, you need, you need, you need Pollock
and I am not going to bring a baby into that!
(audience laughing)
(beeps)
(clears throat)
(audience cheering)
[Casting Director] Name please.
I'm Patton Oswalt.
[Casting Director] Are you ready?
Am I ready to play
Albus Percival Wulfric Brian Dumbledore?
(audience cheering)
I believe yes, I am.
Did Nick Offerman know the whole name?
[Casting Director] No.
No, Nick Offerman didn't know the whole name, hm.
Just real quick, I'm Teen Dumbledore.
Who's playing Young Man Dumbledore?
[Casting Director] Jude Law.
Jude Law.
(audience laughing)
Yeah, that flows.
That's someone I would age into.
But seriously, what is with the wands?
I mean, what are these, like the cell phones
of the wizarding world?
You gotta call down a spell, oh wait, hang on,
I can't cast Patronus, I've only got two bars.
[Casting Director] OK, great, thank you.
(beeps)
(audience cheering)
Name please.
Thomas Middleditch, five foot 10 and some change.
(audience laughing)
[Casting Director] OK.
Alright, you shall not pass!
(audience cheering)
At Hogwarts.
You know what, can I just, I got a whole thing
I wanted to try here.
I think it's more on the teen side of things.
(beeps)
(audience laughing)
Broom.
Broom me, broom.
(grunts)
Oh, what?
It matters not what somebody is born,
but what they grow to be, yeah right.
(audience laughing)
Oh by the way, Hogwarts is lame and learning is for fools.
Peace.
(audience laughing)
(beeps)
(audience applauding)
Hey.
(audience cheering)
I'm Tatiana Maslany.
You know what, maybe he's just shaved.
Maybe he's clean shaven?
[Casting Director] Sure.
(audience laughing)
It does not do to dwell on dreams and forget to live.
I'm a teenager.
(audience laughing)
[Casting Director] Very nice.
Is that okay?
[Casting Director] Now let's try one with--
Yeah, I think you got it.
I think you got plenty actually, OK?
Let's go sweetie, what are you, what is this?
Come on, cut the camera, good.
[Casting Director] We've just got one more.
(beeps)
Name please.
(audience cheering)
Frankie Muniz.
Before I act, just a second, please don't make me
do anything Malcolm in the Middle related.
[Casting Director] Sure, no problem.
And that's when I knew I had them in the palm of my hand.
(audience cheering)
Okay, I'm ready.
Alright.
I vote for Frankie Muniz, I thought he was great.